today we're
the Econo wave project which involves
upgrading vintage speakers with more
modern high frequencies the benefits of
the flat curve instead of the rolled off
highs of this old speaker
the other great thing about this build
is you don't have to hack apart your
speakers you can just set it on the top
this is a compression driver this is a
wave guide it's a modern horn
it features constant directivity this
threads right on the back and then this
is gets installed inside of your speaker
or on top of your speaker these
crossover boards are available from
zilch at I am zilch at ATT net so let's
get to soldering I'm gonna start by
installing a small components first so
we're gonna stuff the board real quick
so I'm putting these leads through the
board and bending them back to hold the
component in place so I'm just gonna go
ahead and solder these in place and clip
them keep in mind as you solder you want
to work fast so that you do not and it
certainly pull these metal bits off the
board with the tip it'll get stuck and
then your project won't work here's the
work I just did
clip the leads this this silks board is
great because it is by amiable you can
use more than one amp one amp to power
the bit the woofers one amp to power the
tweeters I'm going to install these
jumpers now so that we can just round
off of one amp and I just made these
jumpers from from the leads that I
clipped off
let's keep stuffing this board and the
reason that we're double using double
stick tape on the board is because we
don't want these parts vibrating let's
install the inductor if you get stuck at
any point you can refer to the
instructions or go to the forum on audio
karma org link to the magazine article
leads you'd be stripped a little bit so
they make contact on the board you can
see this copper coloring on here we need
to strip that away so that make a proper
connection on the board I need to
install the inductor which also needs
stripping this inductor gets a zip tie
next up we solder the leads to the
woofer and the waveguide I added these
connectors earlier to save a little bit
of time here's our completed crossover
this separates the signal sends the lows
to the lows of the highest of the high
so it protects the highs from being
destroyed by the full signal this would
be a good time to test it this
compression driver is then mounted on
this cheapo $10 JBL waveguide our
crossovers together we just need to
connect to the input terminals to the
crossover where it says in and connect
the speaker cables we are in business
right now we're connecting the board to
the input terminals that we could easily
screw in on the back of the speaker for
easy access to the speaker cables
[Music]